where is my cumin
it's right here hi guys it's your girl
katura king from masterchef and today
we're going to be talking about how to
cook when you are single we're not
talking about any old takeouts or
deliveries no no no today i'm going to
be showing you how to cook some
delicious delightful and delectable
recipes for breakfast lunch and dinner
because let's face it you are the most
important person in your life you might
as well treat yourself and that's
exactly what we'll be doing today from
the beautiful radisson blue in sunny
dakar senegal let's get to these recipes
this is a dish that i first had when i
went to istanbul turkey and i absolutely
fell in love with it so we start with a
good glug of olive oil and we're going
to render some red onions down in that
saute the onions with some chopped green
peppers one of my favorite things about
metamen is the fact that it reminds me
of a middle eastern shakshuka but with a
fun twist and that is a feta cheese now
any dish that contains cheese has my
heart so you have your onions and
peppers rendering down add some tomatoes
in there i prefer fresh diced tomatoes
so once you have those stewed down add
some seasoning black pepper and salt and
of course some oregano a little known
secret about me is i'm actually a
morning person and i like to start the
day off with a bout of meditation i
listen to some affirmations and then i
start with a very healthy breakfast and
lots of black coffee
to add our whipped eggs in there and you
want to do all of this on a low heat so
it doesn't fry up too quickly when it's
almost finished cooking you add your
cheese in and just sprinkle that all
around i believe that you should
definitely take some time out for
yourself in order to really center
yourself so whether that is literally
just sitting down reading a book or
doing some exercise quickly something
just for you in order to set the tone
for the day once you see that it started
to coagulate if you will then just pull
it off the fire you would probably eat
this with some crusty buttered bread
carbs actually make me very sleepy so i
do not eat carbohydrates in the morning
add some fresh herbs to the side an
additional sprinkle of your pepper i
told you i like things really spicy but
of course this isn't optional and then
some sun-dried tomatoes and there you
have it so let's get into it shall we
that's delicious and i'm not just saying
it because i made it the reason it's one
of my favorite dishes is because it's so
creamy and i find the fact that you
don't have to use any butter or milk in
it just that little touch of feta cheese
makes everything so heavenly all right
guys i will see you around lunchtime
now this time for lunch we're making a
greek pink porn salad it's inspired by a
trip that i took to mykonos i had the
time of my life and one thing that i ate
in abundance was seafood and my absolute
favorite king prawn and this is
something that can easily be substituted
with some shrimp or some salmon you can
actually even substitute it with some
chicken if you wanted to now i've
already de-shelled and de-veined these
beauties i tend to use lemon juice you
can also choose to use lime juice i am
going to add some salt and some garlic
powder into that and you really don't
want to put too much garlic powder
because you find that it will overpower
the seafood let's get the olive oil in
there the pan's been heating up for a
while so you'll find that it cooks very
quickly you want to cook your seafood on
a nice high heat i like to flash fry it
quite quickly because you find that once
you take it out it will still continue
to cook let it really crisp up and firm
up if you're using salmon you want it
skin side down if you are using shrimp
or prawns you can flip that over within
two minutes because we've had it on such
a nice high heat you've got a beautiful
little crust on the outer edges of the
corn i will take that off now whilst i
assemble the ingredients for our salad i
like to use generally a lot of different
types of lettuce just to give it a bit
of body use whatever lettuce you can
find so i just rip that up i like to
engage in a lot of self
and some ways that i engage in self-love
i tend to take a nap during the
afternoon being like woken up quite
early in the daytime take that siesta
make sure you revive yourself so let's
get the rest of this salad prepped up we
have some cherry tomatoes that we'll be
adding in there i like to add some red
roasted bell peppers so it adds a little
smoky flavor profile to your salad my
favorite avocado and then we'll add some
fresh red onions in there for a bit of
crunch you don't want to add too much
because let's face it nobody likes onion
breath in the middle of the day add some
cucumbers and next up we're going to add
a grecian favorite of course some olives
now even though you're cooking for
yourself presentation still matters now
for the vinaigrette i like a very heavy
sichuan base a nice little citrus flavor
profile to it so i use not just lemon
juice but also lemon zest that's my
little cheat sheet i add some oregano in
there some dried oregano garlic powder
black pepper let's add some sea salt in
there now this reminds me of one of my
favorite vinaigrettes one of the
dressings that i had whilst i was in
greece one of my favorite things to do
is travel solo it really just brings a
certain sense of self that you don't
experience when you're traveling with
other people i know travel's hard right
now but once the world opens back up do
not be afraid to travel while you're
single so we'll add some dijon mustard
into the base so just whisk your
vinaigrette and so here's the
consistency that you're looking for not
as viscous as perhaps a syrup but
definitely a lot thicker than water
let's say pour that over your salad and
then i like to build it up with a little
more fresh vegetables so we'll add a few
more cherry tomatoes to the top of that
where would we be without our feta
cheese our trusty feta and then you top
it up with our favorite there you have
your wonderful grecian salad nice
luxurious simple healthy flavors can't
wait to dive in
i know you can't taste it but you guys
need to recreate this dish and let me
know exactly what you think this tastes
absolutely divine but i am knackered so
i'm gonna go and have a siesta and i'll
see you guys back here for dinner
okay guys now it's time for our
wonderful dinner preparation and today
i'm making an amazingly authentic
senegalese yasapuli now yasser filet is
one of the best chicken dishes you will
ever have and one of the things that i
love about all the dishes that we've
created today is the fact that they use
very similar ingredients not only do you
get to save on your grocery shopping but
you also get to utilize all of the
things in your pantry so let's get to
the yasa pulae shall we get a chicken
thigh or chicken lab and i like to
generally marinate the chicken with the
yatsapulu marinade overnight if you
don't remember to marinate it the night
before you can always do it two or three
hours prior to creating your dish i like
to score the chicken so you have tasty
skin and also you've got very aromatic
meat as well first things first i'm
going to use a west african maggie brian
q it's west african only because it's
something that we generally use quite a
lot as the base of our dishes in west
africa but you can easily find this in
any supermarket around the world so just
crumble those up add some dried oregano
some black pepper the exact same amount
of white pepper some garlic powder then
i also like to use some fresh garlic and
there are three stars to the show here
the acids in the form of both lemon and
vinegar so i add some zest in there some
fresh lemon juice your secondary acid
which is your vinegar and then we're
going to add dijon mustard and then add
your white onions in so you want the
onions thinly sliced add a bay leaf and
the fun begins now with this you really
gotta get right in there and marinate
and massage your chicken and then we pop
that in the fridge and let it rest for
about two to three hours or preferably
overnight so i have this chicken that i
marinated overnight but we are going to
cook the two together today the
traditional way of making yasakule is to
grill the chicken beforehand to ensure
that you have a nice crust on the
outside in the absence of a grill you
can pan fry it a nice healthy glove of
olive oil in your pan
and your pan has been preheated so it is
going to smoke up very quickly and you
want to get the chicken in skin side
down so we're going to cook each side of
the chicken for about 5-10 minutes on a
very high heat until you see it start to
crust up and become a nice golden brown
so what we're going to do next is add
some water in and let that chicken and
sauce really just simmer and stew you're
going to reduce that fire that you
previously had on a very high heat down
to a low to medium heat add one whole
scotch bunnet in there for those of you
that don't like a lot of heat this is
perfect because you're not exposing the
seeds and that's where all the spice
really is so we're gonna let that simmer
for about 15 to 20 minutes or until it
reaches an internal temperature of about
165 while you move on to making your
accompaniment you can have a green salad
i like to opt for a nice crisp carrot
salad so you add a pinch of cumin in
there our trusty lemon zest some fresh
lemon juice pinch of sea salt and your
olive oil i also like to take some basil
or parsley leaves and slightly bruise
them in the hands chop them up very
roughly put that in there for color and
of course for flavor mix that all up and
that is your very simple side carrot
salad and it's time for us to check and
see if our chicken is ready now what
you're looking for is for the sauce to
reduce down and sort of thickened up and
that is exactly
what we have and what you want to do now
that it's ready to serve is get some
pre-boiled white rice so you want to
serve your chicken thigh over the rice
and then add these juicy onions and if
you like additional heat then you can
take one of the scotch bonnets that you
put in there pop it on the top like so
add your carrot salad to the side and i
like to add some additional fresh herbs
on top so we'll add some additional
color in the form of our char grilled
peppers from earlier and there you have
your traditional senegalese yasakuli
this looks absolutely beautiful so let's
check in to this delectable senegalese
dish
okay
that is good one thing i love about
senegal is the fact that they know food
very simple ingredients but full of
flavor those flavors really burst in
your mouth well that's all for me today
i hope you've enjoyed this trip around
the world from the comfort of your
kitchen i really hope that you do
recreate these dishes and if you do
please be sure to tag me and to all my
single ladies and single men out there
make sure that you love on yourselves i
know these are very strange times that
we're all going through but be sure to
take the time out for yourself each and
every day and remember that you are the
most special person that you will ever
meet bye
[Music]
you